PAULSON: Good evening, welcome. Thank you
very much for coming out on this icy evening.
I'm delighted to be here in Washington.
For those of you who don't know, following
my time as treasury secretary, I returned
to my hometown of Chicago and I spend my time
with the Paulson Institute -- an NGO that's
focused on U.S.-China relations. So, that's
-- that's really how I spend my time.
It's a think-and-do tank; it's focused on
strengthening the relationship between the
U.S. and China with an emphasis on economic
growth -- sustainable economic growth in the
environment and the intersection of those
two.
Now, although we are active in Washington
and we have several of our very important
people here, that I think the last time we
sponsored an event in Washington was 2011.
So, we're just very honored to be cosponsoring
this with the Council on Foreign Relations,
to be here today.
And we have a panel of stellar speakers so
I'm going to be quite brief here because we've
got some -- I think some terrific experts
on China you'll be hearing from in a minute.
But just a few words at the outset, which
I think most of you know, that is the world's
two largest economies, the United States and
China, play a leading role in powering growth,
rebalancing the global economy and ultimately
tackling some of the biggest challenges we
have in the world.
And, you know, we've got some huge ones; I
happen to think that climate change is one
-- one of the -- one of the very biggest ones.
But in today's world, when you think about
almost any of the major challenges, they're
all easier to solve if our two countries are
working together in a complementary way and
they're much, much more difficult if we're
not.
And, you know, on the economic front -- and
that to me is a real fabric of the investment
-- excuse me, the relationship; that's really
-- that is where we have the most important
bridge.
And here I think it is very important that
we continue to work to strengthen that and
-- and we have -- I'll just say a couple words
about the bilateral investment treaty because
I just think that's very, very important and
it's -- it can be a key lever in opening up
Chinese markets for U.S. companies and driving
reform and to the extent we get more Chinese
investment here and the right kind of investment,
it's going to create -- create jobs.
I can think of no threat that poses a greater
risk to the environment or just in -- generally
an economic risk than, as I said earlier,
climate change. And I think the key to solving
this is having the U.S. and China work together
in complementary ways and -- and frankly,
I don't know how we're -- if we have any chance
of solving it if we're not. And so, therefore,
I was very, very encouraged by the breakthrough
that -- that our two governments had at APEC
and I think that's a terrific start on that.
I'll just say one word -- the Paulson Institute
has a -- a number of programs; we have an
air quality and climate program; we've put
together a U.S.-China CEO Urbanization Council
to work on these challenges of energy and
we've got eight outstanding CEOs on each side
and one of those, David Cote of Honeywell,
is -- is here today.
We've got some -- our think tank is putting
out, I think, some, you know, some papers
that are very important on dealing with some
of the fundamental challenges in the energy
and policy area, and across investment.
So, the reason I say this is I think one of
the things it's going to take as we, you know,
work on these major challenges, it takes governments,
it takes the corporate sector and it takes
NGOs all working together -- and -- and hence
the -- the panel tonight.
So, having said that, I'm going to turn it
over to Liz Economy. And as you all know,
she is a real China expert; she's a senior
fellow here. I remember, although as depressing
as it was, it was right, reading her first
book, The River Runs Black. She's -- she's
written another very important book and so,
I'm, as all of you are, looking forward to
listening to this panel moderated by Liz.
So, over to you, Liz.
(APPLAUSE)
ECONOMY: Thank you, Hank, for that lovely
introduction. And let me thank you, as well,
for all the work that you did as treasury
secretary in -- groundbreaking work, really
-- in establishing the foundation for the
U.S.-China economic and environmental relationships.
And I know that everyone here is looking forward
to hearing more about your work and about
your thoughts when your new book dealing with
China is released in April.
Now, on behalf of the Council on Foreign Relations
and the Paulson Institute, let me welcome
everybody here. We really are privileged to
have such a distinguished panel of thinkers
and doers to discuss this evening's topic,
the China Challenge: Balancing Cooperation
and Competition.
I'm just going to briefly introduce all of
the speakers. You have their full bios before
you and, frankly, if I were to take the time
to do the full bios, it would take up all
the time that we have this evening.
And then I'm just going to ask each of them
a question or two to begin the conversation
before opening the floor for questions from
all of you.
Just a few housekeeping notes -- please, everybody,
turn off your phones, your beepers, anything
that may -- might make some noise. This meeting
is on the record, so not traditional Council
style, and we will end promptly at 7:15.
So, without further ado, let me introduce
our speakers. To my immediate right, of course,
is Madeleine Albright. Secretary Albright
is chair of Albright Stonebridge Group, a
global strategy firm, and chair of Albright
Capital Management LLC, an investment advisory
firm that's focused on emerging markets.
She was, of course, most notably the 64th
secretary of state of the United States and
she just returned from Beijing where she participated
in a dialogue between the Aspen Strategy Group
and the Central Party School in China. So,
I know we're going to have some fresh insights
from you on that.
To Secretary Albright's right is Dave Cote.
Mr. Cote was named chairman and CEO of Honeywell
on July 1st, 2002. Under his leadership, the
company has grown from $22 billion in sales
into a highly profitable technology leader
with more than $40 billion in sales today.
Mr. Cote was unsurprisingly named 2013's CEO
of the Year by Chief Executive magazine.
To my left, I have Jon Huntsman. Governor
Huntsman began his career in public service
as staff assistant to President Ronald Reagan.
He has served each of the four U.S. presidents
since then in critical roles around the world,
including as ambassador to Singapore, deputy
assistant secretary of commerce for Asia,
U.S. trade ambassador and, most recently,
U.S. ambassador to China.
He's currently chairman of the Atlantic Council
Board of Directors and co-chair for No Labels.
And last but certainly not least, Jin-Yong
Cai. Dr. Cai joined IFC as executive vice
president and CEO in 2012 following two decades
in the financial services industry. His experience
includes twelve years with Goldman Sachs Group
where he was part of the firm's global leadership
team and he served as the top executive in
China.
At IFC, which is a member of the World Bank
Group, Dr. Cai's work is focused on bringing
private sector solutions to the biggest development
challenges in emerging markets.
So, let me begin by asking all of you the
same question and have you focus on the internal
dynamics of China and then we'll take a step
back and talk about the U.S.-China relationship.
But as you look inside China today, how do
you assess Chinese President Xi Jinping's
first two years in office? What do you see
as the most sort of salient political and
economic features of a Xi-led China and what
do they signify for U.S. interests?
I'll give each of you about four minutes or
so to address this issue and then we'll move
on from there. So, let me start with you,
Governor Huntsman, and ask you to set the
stage for us.
HUNTSMAN: Well, it's -- it's a -- it's a big
question. And let me just begin by -- by saying
this -- you know, I'm a practitioner; I see
a lot of experts in the audience. We're going
to put this relationship to the test, not
necessarily during the years between elections
but, indeed, as we approach 2016.
So, whatever we're experiencing now is likely
to experience a little bit of tumult as we
approach the presidential election, which
is going to put Xi Jinping to the test, along
with his new team. And it's certainly going
to test our side of the system, as well.
I would say that the leadership style that
I'm seeing out of Xi Jinping is rather unprecedented.
I'm not sure that there was any analyst or
expert who necessarily predicted the extent
to which he would consolidate power, the extent
to which he would lead out in a fairly unilateral
and aggressive and assertive fashion.
I think it all kind of is somewhat reflective
of the leadership style more under Mao Zedong
or Deng Xiaoping as compared to anything that
we've seen most recently. I think he's serious
about consolidating power. He's not done yet.
And I think we're likely to see the anti-corruption
campaign pivot from retired senior cadre like
Zhou Yongkang and others to currently-serving
cadre and I think that's going to be a new
and -- and -- and challenging phase for the
system.
I also think his decisionmaking, which is
far different than we saw under Hu Jintao
who was very much by consensus as opposed
to the unilateral approach that Xi Jinping
takes -- I think it's -- it's -- it's facilitated
and aided by a standing committee, which is
different than the standing committee under
Hu Jintao. It's smaller; I think they're more
likeminded. I think he's got some pragmatic
former provincial governors who are really
intent on economic reforms that are absolutely
critical to China's survival going forward.
But what I think I'm most intrigued by, other
than all of the economic reforms that have
been talked about -- teed up at the 18th party
and then built upon at the Third Plenum -- is
a little bit of what we're hearing out of
the Fourth Plenum most recently, which was
on legal and political reform.
So, you know, as we've seen a lot of backsliding
and -- and behavior that has been I think
unseen since 1989, we're beginning to hear
a little bit more about (inaudible), you know,
a country based on rule of law.
I'm not sure that anyone quite knows what
that means but I think there's some sense
of optimism, at least as I see it, that there
is resistance to the old class struggle campaign
and an attempt more to move toward economic
development and a new approach to rule of
law that first will be applied to economics
and trade and inevitably move toward civil
society. I don't know how -- how it won't;
that will take some years to do.
But I think there -- there is a push on the
part of Xi Jinping and some of his likeminded
colleagues to begin to start that debate on
rule of law and -- and even the constitutional
implications of what that means. And I think
we're beginning a very interesting phase here
that again, like the anti-corruption campaign,
is going to be very difficult for the China
watchers to necessarily predict where we're
going.
And then we'll hit the 19th party Congress
and you can already feel it in the air -- the
personnel transitions. An example would be
Mayor Sun of Tianjin, also a member of the
Politburo, who was just put in Ling Jihua's
place as head of the United Front Work program.
So, I think we'll hear more about personnel
issues that are being teed up for the 19th
party Congress. I think that will represent
the end of the consolidation of power in between
the 19th and the 20th party Congresses -- so,
2017 to 2022. I think we're likely to hear
a lot more about reform efforts. And you'll
have -- she will have the solid base with
which to go after the reforms in a fairly
aggressive way.
So, I think the next -- the -- the period
between now and the -- and the 19th party
Congress is going to be very, very interesting
to see who the new personnel selections are
because that will have huge implications with
respect to then the final reform drive up
to the 20th party Congress.
ECONOMY: Great; that's a very positive and
even exciting path forward I think that you've
laid out for China.
Secretary Albright, does that resonate with
you in your recent visit to China? And I know
you've met with President Xi Jinping. How
do you see situation evolving?
ALBRIGHT: Well, yes and no, frankly -- and
I'm delighted to be here and also to be able
to do something with Hank. Your institute
is terrific.
I think that -- I -- I see a lot of what Jon
has said absolutely true in terms of the strength
of the leadership.
What was interesting -- the first time I met
with Xi Jinping, I'd gone over there in a
very peculiar meeting which was Democrats
and Republicans meeting with the International
Department of the Chinese Communist Party.
And we were frankly trying to figure out what
we were doing there and why they wanted the
dialogue and they did introduce us to Xi Jinping.
Then what happened was when he came to the
United States for his visit as vice premier
at the time, he had a bunch of his former
people over to talk for a dinner that he had
set up. And I -- it was interesting because
he was asking us questions in terms of what
we had learned over the three decades of our
relationship -- Hank, you were there -- you
know, in terms of what we had learned about
our relationship. And it struck me as a very
kind of forthcoming, interesting way of trying
to bring us into the whole process.
What -- I have followed everything very closely
and I -- what I see is very much kind of the
tough part that you were talking about, in
terms of consolidating the party.
The meeting that we had -- David was there
-- was one with the Central Party School.
There were a lot of people, all who had exactly
the same thing to say. And so, really kind
of an example of keeping the order together.
I think that he knows that he is dealing with
corruption in the country and he is using
that, I think, very cleverly to rid himself
of people that he doesn't want to deal with.
I think the question on -- we had some private
discussions on the rule -- was it rule of
law or rule by laws and what does -- which
way is it really going and is the translation
even correct and where -- he is providing
a tool for himself, I think, to be able to
do something.
I think there is huge desire within the ruling
groups to have an outward relationship and
to put China in a position where we regard
it with respect. There's an awful lot about
do we use the right words in terms of our
discussion with them; are we condescending
-- a number of kind of nuanced issues on that.
But basically, China is here, China is in
power.
What I found that was interesting was that
this is not particularly a happy time for
business in China because part of what is
going on are some laws that make it more and
more complicated.
So, the anti-monopoly law or issues to do
with cyber -- you can probably talk about
that more, David. But I think basically that
makes it a little bit more complicated in
trying to figure out how things really work.
And a desire to have American business or
foreign investment and especially -- I mean,
if one looks at the numbers of our trade relationship,
you know, it used to be somehow the equivalent
of Honduras and now it's $600 billion. So,
this is a very important relationship to them
and to us.
But some of the -- the laws and decrees that
are coming out I think make it complicated
and the regulations and which bureaucracy's
in charge -- which I think there's a little
bit to do with this sense of how do we obey
the new way of looking at things. So, as everything
that's ever been written about a bureaucracy
is true...
(LAUGHTER)
And so, there is this kind of sense -- how
to carry out the regulations and not delete
their own power and yet be able to follow
and do what the leader wants.
I think he's very impressive; there's no question.
And I think that the possibility -- Hank,
you were talking about the agreement on climate
change. I think that's a really big deal -- that
he could do that is definitely a sign of the
power of somebody.
And this is the important part. Here is a
man who sees himself in office for many, many
years -- who thinks he's going to see a lot
of different American presidents and that
he -- our foreign policy comes in four year
segments, his is going to come as a longer
time and that kind of sense of being there
for a long time I think is very important.
What is interesting despite what I said is
that there is a desire to get American help
in a number of ways. And domestically, for
instance, I met with the health minister.
She made it very clear that they have problems
in their health care system; they would like
to get some advice from the United States,
try to figure out how we can work together...
(LAUGHTER)
It depends on who you're for. But -- or for
instance, issues to do with food safety or
farming that there are a variety of issues
on which we can help.
I do think where there is an issue, and we'll
talk more about U.S.-Chinese relations, there
is no question that as one looks at the history
of the U.S.-Chinese relationship, the business
community has been the greatest supporter
of it.
And if, in fact, it becomes more complicated
to do business, then some of the issues to
do with human rights and a variety of other
issues will make it more difficult on the
relationship.
So, I find it fascinating to watch what he's
doing. I agree, in terms of he's much more
like Deng Xiaoping or Mao. But here is a really,
really strong leader who sees himself in there
for a very long time, who has the tools to
adjust the system in a way to refurbish the
Communist Party and put it back central and
also to deal with people that he doesn't like.
The question is -- and I always have this
question anywhere -- if you create a middle
class, which he has done, at what point do
they want to be part of the system and have
a voice and -- and -- and what happens to
a political system that's top-down when you
have created a middle class?
ECONOMY: I think we'll come back later and
have you address just that question, because
I think it is one of the most central questions
in China today.
So, let me use your excellent introduction
to the issues of business in China to ask
Mr. Cote to talk a little bit about how you
see the reform process underway in China today
-- what it means for Honeywell in particular
because I know you have your fingers in almost
every part of economic pie in China, from
infrastructure to energy to environmental
technology. So, what do you see coming out
of Xi's first two years?
COTE: Yeah, from my perspective, his first
two years have been impressive.
And just to put it into perspective, we now
have 12,000 employees in China. And two years
ago, China became the biggest country outside
the U.S. for our company sales. So, we've
made a pretty big commitment because I really
believe that China could be the economic story
of the 21st century.
And the stuff that we've seen him doing has
been I think very good. The whole anti-corruption
push which we could say has a dark side to
it also -- at the end of the day, is unbelievably
needed and unbelievably supported by the population.
I mean, my own employees talk about the stories
that they see in the press every day, in the
Chinese press, and how important they think
that is to see this happening.
The commitment on climate change I thought
was impressive. The population supports him
in it.
The concern that I have about it is exactly
what Madeleine was talking about -- is once
somebody's accumulated and consolidated power,
can they transition? And if they can't transition,
well, a lot of the things that we hope are
possible for China I think are going to be
suspect.
When it comes to how are we looking at China,
oftentimes the stuff I've read in the past
showed China's development compared with Japan's
and they look at it that way. And I've always
thought that was the wrong analogy and that
the real comparison for us is going to be
this is going to be how the U.S. works with
China in this century. It's going to be a
lot more akin to what happened to the U.S.
and the U.K. from 1830 to 1870.
The U.K. started off as the bigger economy
than the U.S. Over that forty years, our population
eclipsed them, our -- our regard in how we
looked at business, how we encouraged business,
caused us to really outstrip them. We were
focused on the -- even though they started
the industrial revolution, we really focused
on it and Americanized everything, especially
mass production. And we totally eclipsed their
economy.
I think that same thing could happen in the
21st century because they already have almost
four times the number of people that we do.
And as long as they focus on the right things
like they have historically, they could very
well get there.
So, I really think eighty-five years from
now when people look back on this century,
the question is going to be how good a job
did our two countries do getting along and
how did we develop our relationship together?
And I think it's entirely possible for those
people who write all the books about confrontations
eleven out of fourteen times when countries
have been this big and this has happened -- I
really just don't think that has to be the
way this is.
And I keep pointing to the U.K. that I just
described and how we look at them as our most
important allies -- and it was 200 years ago
that they burned down our White House.
(LAUGHTER)
It was 150 years ago that we worked to keep
them neutral in the Civil War. And somehow,
we've managed to make this work.
We need to be able to do the same thing with
China. We need to build our own competitiveness
agenda and we need to be doing a lot more
in the U.S. than we are today.
But at the same time, we have to do everything
we can to improve commercial and peaceful
ties. That doesn't mean we just give up and
-- and let them do whatever they want, but
we need to always keep that in mind -- that
this is going to be an important relationship
to develop.
And it's one of the reasons I like to focus
on climate change and the discussions that
the president had because I think that's a
nice, peaceful way to accomplish a common
objective. We understand their needs to develop;
they also understand the needs to drive improvements
to prevent climate change and I think that's
a nice way to start building ties and making
sure this ends up being a peaceful economic
evolution rather than the way it could go
if -- if both countries aren't smart about
it.
ECONOMY: Great.
OK, Dr. Cai, you bring a unique perspective
to the panel. You grew up in China, you've
worked in China and you've worked with the
Chinese government. Give us your perspective
on Xi Jinping's reform plans. Where -- where
is it succeeding, where is it lagging, what's
-- what do you see?
CAI: First of all, I'm very humbled to be
on this panel and in front of my -- my boss.
(LAUGHTER)
So, you know, I -- I'm very optimistic. I
think so far for last two years, Xi Jinping
definitely demonstrated he's the boss; he's
going to lead the China to overcome many other
countries have failed, which is called a middle
income trap.
And when you look at all the issues -- corruption,
environmental degradation -- and, you know,
from my perspective, having the financial
sector -- a huge accumulation of risk in the
-- in the system. The fundamental issue is
really over the last many years China has
been lucky in benefiting the global economic
progress -- you know, WTO, U.S. market -- and
build up a system very hard to continue.
The business model is not going to work anymore
in the future. But the key success factor
in the past business model is really the relationship
between the government and the -- and the
market.
The (inaudible) remember -- they're always
saying China is a different model, state of
capitalism. By the way, you know, right now
the Chinese is the first one to say it's not
working.
So, you look at the 18th party Congress and
also the Third Plenary Session -- there's
a key phrase, which is, the center of the
economic reform is allow the market to become
the decisive means to allocate resources.
And when you look at the system, it's -- you
know, we look at the -- the cadre of Chinese
Communist Party for last thirty years -- what
they know? They know to create GDP; and if
you do a great job, 10 percent, 14 percent,
get promoted.
And the -- everyone is like -- the mayor is
a CEO; the provincial governor is a CEO. And
when you have -- the governments believe they
can -- they can do wonders. And that's where
the corruption is; that's where the, you know,
kind of -- I would say damaging the environment
for my own promotion really at the expense
of the future generation.
So, yes, there are all this political -- what
they call -- pretty harsh anti-corruption.
I think in a country of this size with the
momentum, the leadership not only at the top
-- actually, it's throughout the country -- the
only I'll say means people know how to get
promoted, how to really get recognized is
creating new GDP; we need discipline. But
how will we get that discipline?
And by the way, another very important development
over last, you know, ten years, or twenty
years, a lot of wealth has been created. So,
there are a lot of entrenched interests.
So, in a way, the tough measure of anti-corruption,
why it's so supported by the public is because
people realize unless there's a fundamental
governance reform, the country will get into
deep trouble.
And I think if you look at the team he has,
at least on the economic front, I think he
has the A team in China -- and certainly you
have Prime Minister Li. And equally important,
you know, Hank knows all of them and the governor
-- central bank governor, the minister of
finance and the -- what they call Council
of Economic Advisors. These are the people,
you know, I have been lucky to know; they
are fundamentally market-based thinker.
But they are also not what I would call ideology-driven;
they want to know in their next few years
what are the decisive actions they can take
to really stop this very rapid-growing moving
train to really, you know, move the direction.
And if you are in China, Madeleine, you must
have heard there's a phrase called the 'xin
chang tai' -- new norm. Everyone talking about
new norm -- what does that mean?
New norm from the economics angle really are
very simple. GDP is no longer the target.
If you read the newspaper, Shanghai government
for the first time no longer set any GDP target.
Number two is, no one's going to be rewarded
if you are keep doing business not serving
the people, i.e., you are not really serving
-- government has to be a service provider,
not running a company.
And when you think of all the corruptions,
it's mainly because there's too much power
in the government, in the -- you know, in
the mayor, in the provincial hands. They can
go to the bank, they can do all this -- have
a lot of ease -- very easy to make money.
And they are also very focused on make sure
the overcapacity, a massive amount of literally
-- I will say mid-level products -- has to
stop because it's creating huge risks for
the financial system.
So, you know, you can do this in the very,
you know, Wall Street type -- Wall Street
Journal type of description. But there's one
document I want to draw your attention -- I
think it's critical to demonstrate the leadership
determination. This is called the 'zhongyang
yihao wenjian' -- the 43rd document of the
State Council. It's called Strengthening the
-- and the -- "Strengthening the Regulation
of Local Government Debt."
This is a fundamental piece of document. I
think will fundamentally change the -- how
China can run between -- among different level
of government, between the government and
the business. Just give you a quick snapshot
on this -- I'd really encourage you to -- to
look at this.
And by the way, the -- the genesis of this
document basically is saying, look, the local
government has been financing this GDP, you
know, through shadow banking, you -- you know,
these wealth management products, and through
variety of local government financing vehicles.
Even the Chinese government at center they
even do not know how many. Based on the current
numbers, about more than 7,000 debt-issuing
entities borrowing.
And they use this money to finance two things.
One is really a -- infrastructure. Every city
want to build the tallest building; everyone,
you know, doing something. And another thing
is trying to create a business because that's
creating tax for them.
And because the government take away so much
liquidity from the system, that has created
a huge problem for private sector to develop.
And the central government realized, Lou Jiwei
in particular, and certainly the whole government
realized this is not sustainable.
What they did is basically they say, OK, by
the end of December 31st, 2014, we're going
to call a staff of any local government ability
to raise debt. We're going to look at exactly
what we have, basically -- about how much
-- about 18 trillion RMB right now -- estimate;
and that's more than $2.5 trillion, all at
the local government level, spread at about
more than seven (inaudible), you know, different
variety of things.
Basically, they are going to say from now
on, we're going to look at all this debt liability.
If the debt liability is for the public, i.e.,
infrastructure, the central government will
take over. From now on, local government cannot
issue any debt unless you go to the People's
Congress of your local community.
So, you open up a transparency and the local
government right now -- they realize there's
no more money -- free money anymore. And when
you have your debt issued with approval, local
People's Congress, what do you get? You're
going to -- people are going to check what
are -- what are you doing -- where the money
has gone; what's your liability?
So, fundamentally, this has opened up the
transparency of government at a county, at
a city and a provincial level. This is, in
my view, fundamental change in China. And
in my view, it's going to really define the
border between the government and market.
And most interesting thing is going forward,
the governments -- you can still issue debt,
by the way. But what you need to do is you
have to say what is that for. Is building
public, you know, public goods, or you are
doing for your recurrent expenditure? Not
that it would be allowed to issue for financing
your so-called recurrent expenditure.
So, there are many, many fundamental change,
only a -- you know, not really (inaudible)
in Wall Street Journal, in my view. I think
he's focused on the right thing. I think,
you know, I feel if he continues this path,
the leadership will be able to move the China
into the right direction.
ECONOMY: Thank you.
So, one thing that I think we've sort of touched
on but haven't really addressed, and I -- I'd
like to get anybody's opinion on this before
we transition to discussion of the U.S.-China
bilateral relationship more explicitly -- is
whether the political tightening that is clearly
underway in China today, sort of the push
through on the ideological front, through
think tanks in universities and sort of the
entire political system -- whether that is
-- contradicts Xi Jinping's economic objectives
-- his reform objectives, whether it's a sort
of short-term strategy designed to assist
in achieving those objectives -- what do you
see as the sort of linkage between what's
happening in the political sphere and the
economic sphere? Any takers?
ALBRIGHT: Well, I would say that there is
a result which I mentioned earlier, which
is if you want to have a consumer society,
if you want to figure out how to deal with
the local places, to what extent can you really
maintain centralized control?
And an awful lot of what he is doing is trying
to kind of restore an ideology and a sense
of purpose and the -- the whole kind of drive
of who is China that he, in fact, has created
a certain contradiction that he's going to
have to deal with.
And one of the issues in China is obviously
also the division between urban and rural,
Communist or not, between rich and poor. And
so, there are certain, I think, various things
that we feel in other societies that are going
to have to be dealt with in China and there
is truly a problem between overly centralized
government and a -- a one party system and
the forces of the market. And at some point,
they're going to have to face that also.
HUNTSMAN: I think the bottom line for Xi and
the regime is you cannot get -- and Dave Shambaugh's
written about this not so long ago -- you
can't get to the next level of economic development
without fundamental legal and political reform,
period, because you cannot have a society
based on innovation or creativity or rule
of law or business adjudication; it's all
ad hoc-ery and at the whims of bureaucrats.
So, and -- and I think Xi Jinping knows it.
So, let's break it into phases. You've got
-- you've got the first phase which is consolidation
of power, which is what he's doing. And when
you're consolidating your power, I don't care
where -- where you are as a leader, I -- I
never did this as governor, though...
(LAUGHTER)
When -- when you consolidate power, you know,
you -- you cut off dissenting voices and opinions.
And so, the real test will be as we kind of
emerge beyond just the consolidation of power
anti-corruption campaign into the 19th party
Congress, are we seeing more of the green
shoots as it relates to rule of law, maybe
even talk of civil society?
I know that's way premature but you know,
I'm an optimist or I wouldn't be in this business.
I can't help but think that that ultimately
is where the population will take this over
time.
So, and I think Xi knows that without the
economic reforms bolstered by certain rule
of law and political reforms, China cannot
create the economy necessary -- necessary
to provide its long-term stability, which
is his ultimate goal.
COTE: And I -- I would agree on the -- I think
a lot of the things -- the changes that he's
making could be very good for the economy
because to get to the next level, I would
agree -- you have to build trust in your institutions.
People have to be able to trust those institutions
and we can all complain about them and some
of the decisions courts might make, at the
same time.
But at the end of the day, if you've got some
faith, some trust that people are trying to
do the right thing in government, then that
ends up being a good thing for development.
Anybody who's spent any time in China -- I
always found it kind of interesting when even
some people who might have spent some time
there -- they would describe it as a totalitarian
system. So, tend to think of it as a monarchy
or a dictatorship and one guy decides what
happens and then everybody goes and does it.
One of the problems they're running into is
the fact that the provinces don't necessarily
listen to the central command. And I always
say if you want to get a sense for how well
a people actually listen to the government,
get a police escort in Beijing. And as you
start driving down the street trying to go
from the airport into the city, no one listens
to the cops.
(LAUGHTER)
They're yelling at them through the megaphone
and they're looking in their window, in their
mirror...
HUNTSMAN: Kind of like Washington.
COTE: ...and they're not moving because they
want to get their first. And you say, OK,
other totalitarian systems I visited, people
listen to the cops.
(LAUGHTER)
So, it's not exactly the way we describe it.
So, I can understand the need to consolidate
some of the power in order to be able to get
things done.
The thing I really worry about, getting back
to the trust in institutions, is, can he transition.
At some point, when the time is done, can
he pass it on to somebody else who can continue
the good work and recognize where it is they're
trying to go building faith in their institutions?
But overall, right now I think it's a positive.
ECONOMY: OK, great.
So, I have a whole set of sort of U.S.-China
issue-specific questions like cybersecurity
and climate change but we have reached a moment
where I think as chair, I really ought to
open the discussion to all of you. And we
have such an amazing audience that I'm sure
there are going to be a lot of really terrific
questions.
So, let me now open the floor for questions
from all of you. We have microphones so please
wait for a microphone to get to you. Please
identify yourself before you ask your question
and also just keep your questions and comments
relatively concise.
Great, and I already see some hands. Why don't
we start right here?
QUESTION: Thank you. I'm Dan Yergin.
Governor Huntsman, you diplomatically refer
to the risk of some tumult in U.S.-Chinese
relations between now and 2016. I wonder if
you all would like to riff on what that tumult
will be, and in particular, whether the South
China Sea controversies could be something
that could inadvertently derail the relationship.
HUNTSMAN: Thanks, Dan, for not asking a question
on energy.
(LAUGHTER)
You know, having stood on the stage during
the last election cycle, the narrative of
the U.S.-China relationship goes south real
fast because it's -- it's an easy villain
for people to identify, to caricature and
to threaten.
So, at a time when we need a discussion about
a vision that bolsters the U.S. generally
-- the most important relationship in the
world, the one that gives context to our long-term
aspirations together -- I fear that we're
going to get a replay of what we had last
time, which is opportunistic discourse on
not what you're going to do with China, but
what you're going to do to China.
And so, this does a couple of things. It sets
us back in terms of the progress we -- we
need to be making together, not on the issues
where we disagree, the -- there are plenty
of those and we have time to talk about -- but
issues where we do agree and how we can help
shape the world together because increasingly,
it must happen between the two of us as participants.
So -- so, it's lost opportunity on one side.
Second, I think when you have the -- the -- the
totality of the candidates who begin to just
take the opportunity, there then is the punishment
period on the part of the Chinese when you
come up on the other side. So, whoever wins
the election is put kind of in the penalty
box, if you will. Six month cooling off period
-- is it a year cooling off period? You know
what I'm talking about.
(LAUGHTER)
In -- in -- in which -- in which the work
that really needs to get done shaped by a
vision discussed with the American people
during a campaign, which is what campaigns
are supposed to be about, doesn't happen.
So, it's lost opportunity for the next three
years.
And I just wonder about the patience on the
other side where Xi Jinping is consolidating
power, he wants to strike some important agreements
with the United States that will be part of
his legacy. And if we're not in the game to
play for the long term, which has always been
a tough thing for the United States, he'll
go someplace else. And then we're really behind
in the game -- and that's what I fear could
result from the missed opportunity of 2016.
ECONOMY: OK, I think you had your hand up
next right there, in the middle?
QUESTION: Thank you. Don Clarke, GW Law School.
I have a question for Dr. Cai. So, you mentioned
that Xi Jinping's goal is to replace the standard
of assessment for government officials. Instead
of, you know, how well do you produce stuff,
you know, how much GDP in your district, et
cetera, it's going to be how well you serve
the people.
So, I mean, this raises the question of how
you kind of operationalize that standard.
You know, if -- the best people to judge whether
you're serving the people, you know, are of
course the people. But, you know, democratic
accountability downward is really off the
table.
So, China is sort of stuck with the current
system, which is kind of bureaucratic ability
-- sorry, accountability upward. And some
things are easy to measure when you're doing
that and some things are hard to measure.
So, things like GDP -- that's very easy to
measure and it's not easy to, you know, not
-- relatively not easy to, you know, tweak
through corruption.
But if you're doing -- if you're trying to
measure serving the people, I mean, that's
very hard to measure when you're trying to
do it through numbers that are reported to
your superior. So, how exactly could the standard
really be operationalized?
CAI: It will be hard. And you talk about the
risk, right? It's -- it's all the execution
risk, right, not being -- look at the leadership,
they talk about right things, they analyze
the whole issues. I mean, not only on the
GDP and the what to do with -- we talk about
intellectual property. You know, it's amazing
that they are talking about unless we protect
intellectual property, no one's going to innovate;
all these things.
I think there will be a, you know, from distance,
look at -- China's truly a authoritarian -- whatever
we describe it. But there enough channel -- it's
not on political issue in terms of challenging
the party -- one party rule. But on a lot
of other things, you do have a pretty good
channel to say, hey, the traffic is bad; the
water pollution -- the river runs black and
the schools are not doing well.
So, I think -- let's start from basic health
care. There -- the Chinese have spent more
than 3 trillion RMB to reform the health care
system; it's really not working out. The World
Bank tried to be helpful. So, there are a
lot of those things -- basic needs.
The middle class, right, now, they're looking
for a better quality of service. So, this
is not as hard as if, you know, we have to
really go a long way to reflect because, you
know, if you go to any Chinese hospital in
any big city or small city, it's not a very
comfortable experience. This has to be changed.
So, I would say there are a lot of visible
program -- visible area -- they have to do
it. And there are a lot of other areas not
that easy to -- to discern. But, you know,
let's deal with the low-hanging fruit first.
So, I think -- I'm not I'll say pessimistic
as if there's no channel feeding up what's
going on -- if progress has been made.
By the way, you know, one -- one of the biggest
issues -- 250 million migrant workers -- they
live in the city. Their children cannot go
to school and this is a big problem. Really,
is very, very -- you know, both make the people
who live in the city and not in the city very
uncomfortable.
So, these are the issues I think -- if you
talk about many other issue we need to deal
with, this probably the first thing -- basic
needs of -- of the people.
ECONOMY: Great.
Yes? And if you could stand, please, when
you ask your question? Oh, it's David.
QUESTION: David Sandalow, Columbia University.
I'll ask the climate energy question. So,
could you place the climate agreement in the
context of the overall U.S.-China relationship?
What does it reflect about the relationship,
what are the implications for the relationship
and what are the opportunities for U.S. business?
ECONOMY: Do you want to...
ALBRIGHT: Well, let me -- first of all, I
do think that it was a -- a truly important
agreement between two individuals, frankly,
very important to each of them for their agenda.
I think knowing, however, how complicated
the whole climate story is and where it's
going in terms of the international -- the
Paris meetings and all the various parts -- there's
the bilateral and then the multilateral part
of this that will be complicated -- but I
think it's a big step forward. Having been
in negotiations previously where we couldn't
get anywhere, I think that it is a big step
forward.
I think the issue generally, though, on issues
-- when issues are complicated between two
countries, you say they're multifaceted; this
is definitely multifaceted relationship. And
-- and I do think that one plays off of another.
There will be questions to do with energy
and there will be questions to do with the
South China Sea. And certainly those are the
kinds of issues that will come up during a
campaign.
And, I do think that one of the other issues
that's out there in terms of domestic politics
is that one of the ways that you globalize
a population is by letting loose the whole
concept of nationalism and that is partially
what is going on in terms of the Chinese have
been put upon by everybody, including mostly
the Japanese.
But -- but basically, that nationalism is
out there and will be brought forward if,
in fact, in some of these negotiations it
is evident that China has had to make concessions
on issues. So, I think that that's where the
domestic and foreign come together.
I do think from our perspective the climate
change is a big deal, but it is the first
step in a complex, multifaceted relationship.
ECONOMY: Do you want to say something? Yeah.
COTE: If I could, I -- for the same reasons
I mentioned before, I liked the agreement
because I thought it was a -- a peaceful commercial
way to develop a -- a stronger relationship
between our two countries.
I also liked it because I thought there was
a recognition that China still needed to develop
and as they developed, emissions would grow,
but that they found a way to say "we'll peak
in 2030" and then they'll start to go down.
So, I thought that was a nice indication that
the two countries could work together.
The potential for U.S. companies is quite
good because we have a lot of technologies
that could be helpful to them. If you take
a look at the sulfur content of their fuel,
for example, removing all that sulfur before
they put it into their cars; turbochargers
that can help them on miles per gallon; the
new kinds of refrigerants that you can use
that have GWP below 1.0 -- there's a lot of
stuff that's developed in the West.
The smart cities development -- they've got,
say, another 300 million people that need
to move from the farms to the city. They're
going to have a chance to develop cities that
make a lot more sense than the ones that we
all developed in the West over centuries.
And U.S. technology can be quite important
for them in thinking through how do you make
a smart city work. So, I think there's a lot
of play and opportunity for U.S. companies
here.
ECONOMY: Can I just ask -- do you see those
opportunities already for the U.S. environmental
technologies? I remember a few years back,
the market seemed to be largely one where
the Chinese were saying, this is an area where
we ourselves can make a lot of progress, we're
not necessarily interested in opening up so
widely to U.S. companies.
COTE: Yeah, I would have to put it on a continuum
and say it's shifted a bit. But there's still,
for example, low sulfur fuel technology -- something
we have today but they're trying strongly
to develop it internally. The problem is it
never goes quite as fast because it's tougher
than they -- than they think.
So, yes, that's still a problem, but I think
you're going to start to see that shifting.
And we see it in smart city development, for
example, where they -- they really want a
lot of perspective from the -- from the U.S.
HUNTSMAN: I -- I think it's a really big deal,
David. We've worked on these issues before,
we know the -- the complexity of it.
I was surprised, frankly -- although, when
you look at it closely, you know, I can't
help but think, you know, that what the Chinese
like to say, you know, they never forget anything
and we Americans never remember anything...
(LAUGHTER)
So -- so, who's going to be around in 2030?
I don't know. And -- and how do we work it
out based on our domestic politics in America
where Hank is one of the few Republicans I
know who can say the words climate change
without stuff being thrown at him.
(LAUGHTER)
I don't know how we move the issue through
our system such that we have at least a policy
response, regardless of who the next president
is. It's important; the implications are enormous.
Peak levels by 2030 and effectively a renewable
portfolio standard that goes with that, I
think -- I think China inexorably is moving
there, not because they think it's -- it's
good policy as much as the political system
is forcing them to -- the people of the country
are forcing them in that direction because
of the poor air quality. And so, we'll see
how that goes.
CAI: OK, can I just comment on the...
ECONOMY: OK, quickly, quickly.
CAI: Yeah, there are two area -- I think one's
a nuclear -- they talk about a view -- nuclear
reactor. China has a plan to build fifty,
five-zero, nuclear reactors. And they view
that as a key part of reducing emission.
Another very important area is agriculture
-- smart agriculture, you -- has a lot of
things to offer. You know, the one example
is Smithfield -- right now I think produce
a lot more pork in this country and export
that to China. This has really spread into
many other area in agriculture.
ECONOMY: Thank you.
OK, back there -- you've had your hand up
for a bit.
QUESTION: Thank you. Richard Downie from Delphi
Strategic Consulting. Thank you for a great
discussion; very interesting.
A couple of you have obliquely mentioned cybersecurity
and I'll touch on it because I think cybersecurity
is really one of those issues that stresses
this topic of competition versus cooperation.
I mean, the Chinese have tremendous capabilities
in cyber and we've seen their ability to hack
into our companies and they have made -- it's
intellectual property that's very similar
to some of ours. You know, it's -- cybersecurity,
it's very difficult to -- to deter in this
area. But, you know, intellectual property
is -- is an issue.
I wonder -- are any of you optimistic that
there is a framework that we can be cooperative
in this -- this area, versus competition?
Thank you.
ECONOMY: Let me ask you, Governor Huntsman,
because...
HUNTSMAN: Yeah, I -- I would agree that it's
-- it's an enormously important issue between
our two countries. It's -- it's right now
bad for both sides.
So, I -- we did a study, I co-chaired it with
Admiral Denny Blair on particularly the intellectual
property theft side, which is one that I think
we ought to think more about. You have the
espionage side -- that's going to have to
be worked through channels that can draw red
lines around whatever.
But the theft of intellectual property, which
is robbing us of jobs, ideas and innovation,
is a real deal. And we assess the level of
injury to the United States to be about 300
billion bucks a year, which is a huge deal.
So, it's bad for China because, you know,
why does China do -- why does anybody do it?
Because they're low-hanging opportunities.
You can take them; there are no rules of the
road, there's no real punishment and you can
advance your technology base.
The bad part of that is China's advancing
some of their technology base without the
ecosystem or the infrastructure that is needed
to really give sustenance to those technologies.
We built them here, we developed them, we
nurtured them in research universities, we
take them to the marketplace.
By China taking them, they don't have the
support system that would really allow them
to -- to be viable over time, even if there
were equal rules of the road. So, that's bad
for China. It's bad for us just because of
the innovation that is stolen.
So, I'd say what do we do about it? It's a
hard issue to talk about because we have no
real answers. It's the Wild West still.
I look at the five PLA officers who were charged
in May of last year for ripping off secrets
from U.S. Steel, Westinghouse -- maybe there
were one or two other companies. What's come
of it? Nothing so far as I can tell. And I
remember in 2006 when, you know, unit 61398
was stood up in Pudong right about when the
indigenous innovation drive started.
And so, there -- it's a real issue. And I
fear that the only answer long term -- and
I wish we had something short term -- is the
new generation of entrepreneurs and innovators
putting pressure on their own government because
it begins to affect their ability to globalize
and to take a good name into the marketplace.
And, you know, so I lived in Taiwan in 1987,
1988 with the Hsinchu Industrial Park when
the DRAMs were being built. And they turned
pretty quickly in terms of their own respect
for intellectual property rights because they
had an indigenous movement that did so.
Finally, I'll just -- I'll just offer this
-- we recommended in our report that you need
leverage in the game to get anybody's attention
on this. So, why not look at access to the
marketplace, the U.S. marketplace, and make
intellectual property theft through cyber
means or any other means part of the SEC review
process if you want to take a company public,
part of the CFIUS review process, and part
of financial transactions much like we do
when we sanction banks who launder money out
of, say -- say, North Korea.
So, what has the administration not done?
Well, nobody's looked real seriously about
how you respond based on market leverage.
And then centralizing somebody who actually
owns the issue within the administration,
which -- and unless you do that, put in the
hands of the national security advisor, I
don't know how you elevate it high enough
to where it really begins to take effect.
ECONOMY: Yes?
COTE: As a recipient of numerous attacks from...
(LAUGHTER)
All kinds of countries, I can say it's the
-- to use an old Washington phrase, I guess,
it's the known unknown that has always scared
me the most...
(LAUGHTER)
Because you -- no matter how much you tried
to protect yourself, you can't be sure that
there isn't something already happening.
The issue that we run into is it's -- your
border's no longer defined by a 200 mile limit.
So, the -- the -- if all of the sudden a hundred
people of another nationality landed on Long
Island, we'd know what to do. When they sit
in another country attacking with their computer,
we don't know what to do.
And from my perspective, there needs to be
a treaty of some kind. We need to evolve to
the point where we can -- and we can figure
out where an attack is coming from despite
the point about servers attacking -- you know,
everybody can figure out where it's coming
from. We need some kind of treaty between
countries to say that you -- they're not going
to do this.
And I agree on the whole point of innovation.
If you're going to have an innovation culture,
you can't do it by stealing all the time.
It doesn't -- it can help you get jumpstarted;
remember, we did the same with the U.K.
(LAUGHTER)
But at some point, you have to stop and do
it on your own if you're really going to evolve
your system.
ECONOMY: Great. Yes?
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE) Joanne Leedom-Ackerman
from PEN International.
ECONOMY: Use the microphone -- sorry.
QUESTION: Joanne Leedom-Ackerman from PEN
International.
I'll bring up the big word -- human rights
and freedom of expression. Obviously a society
doesn't develop if it cannot have free expression,
dissent, et cetera. What do you think the
most productive way is to go forward as America
in our relationships with China with these
issues without, you know, hounding in a way
that's unproductive, but I don't think it's
an issue that can be ignored?
ALBRIGHT: Well, I -- I think it's absolutely
not an issue that can be ignored. And the
bottom line is -- is that when you do have
negotiations, if you don't bring it up, then
you are not doing your job as an American
representative.
And so, I think we do have to raise it; we
have to always make clear -- and some of it
does have to do with cyber, frankly, in terms
of under what circumstances do they want all
the -- the codes on people that are in banks;
that's one of the stories that are coming
up now. And I think that we need to link those
issues. And I think it's a mistake if we decide
that in this multifaceted relationship, that
we will kind of be silent about it.
And -- and I think one of the issues here,
and it goes a little bit to the question about
what happens at the bottom of the pyramid
-- because people are trying to express themselves
with the problems that are there on water
and food. And if there's some reason why we
had these meetings with the international
department of the party, I think they were
trying to figure out how we relieve pressure
at the bottom of the pyramid in terms of being
able to have people express their views.
And so, I think we have to present the issue
of the capability of -- and it has to do with
innovation, et cetera, that a society is much
better off if it, in fact, allows some expression
of views. So, we have to present it not just
as something that we care about but that ultimately
that helps their society.
ECONOMY: Terrific. Yes?
QUESTION: Thank you very much. Teresa Barger
from Cartica Capital.
We live in an era where it's very tempting
to have competitive devaluations but we have
not seen the Chinese engage in devaluing the
renminbi when everyone else is getting devalued
all around them.
And there's a debate raging among the pundits
-- some say, oh, well they are going to once
they get really terrified when their exports
fall off. And there's another school of thought
that says, this is a great opportunity for
the Chinese to bring everybody up the value
chain. And, in fact, a more expensive exchange
rate is better for them to advance that agenda.
And so, I'm just wondering what the -- the
-- since there are two views, what the views
of the panel are.
ECONOMY: Dr. Cai, you want to take it?
CAI: Yeah, I think I agree with you. I think
they are looking at this from much more automatic
economy reform perspective. And the -- yes,
there have been a lot of export in the past
and the truth is they realize it's not worth
it. They basically pollute the environment,
pollute the water -- exports for very marginal
kind of a gain.
And another very important consideration is
really the RMB internationalization. If you
want to be a credible currency, you better
make sure you -- you have a market-driven
kind of exchange rate or interest rate mechanism.
So, I feel, you know, the second thought is
much more close to the decisionmakers' mind.
When you look at what they are doing, it's
very much focused on domestic reform to move
up the value chain. So, I think the chance
of competitive devaluation conducted by the
central bank is very, very small.
ECONOMY: Great. Yes, right there, in the center?
QUESTION: Thanks, hi. Marty Weiss with the
Congressional Research Service.
My question is about the bilateral relationship
in the context of the IMF, the World Bank
and the multilaterals. As, you know, quota
reform at the IMF to increase China's share
isn't going anywhere, China at the same time
is playing a much more sort of role establishing
the Asian -- the Infrastructure Investment
Bank, and other type of entities, as well.
What should the right U.S. response be? How
should the U.S. balance its interest in protecting
our safeguards, our priorities? The -- the
World Bank and the Asian Development Bank
is, you know, in their role while also trying
to shape China's choices as, you know, the
inevitable occurs -- as they create these
types -- these new entities?
ECONOMY: Governor Huntsman, you want to take
that?
HUNTSMAN: Oh, I think -- I think China is
very adverse to U.S.-centric institutions.
I think they'd like to build some of their
own. I think the Infrastructure Bank is the
latest example -- maybe even a trial balloon
in trying to do just that, to see how the
region would respond. And of course Korea,
Japan, and Australia didn't respond favorably.
I -- I think we took the wrong approach on
that. I think instead of threatening, trying
to create two separate worlds, why not shape
it? Why not help to shape a common destiny?
I think that was a fundamental mistake.
But we'll see where institution building goes.
I think we're just on the front end of some
other attempts by -- by China to create regional
institutions, maybe headed toward global institutions,
that help to balance America's role in the
world. I think fundamentally, that's -- that's
what they seek.
CAI: I have a -- because I work in the World
Bank?
ECONOMY: Sure.
(LAUGHTER)
CAI: I think China want to -- to play ball.
And, you know, this -- this -- the Chinese,
when you think about it, they've gone through
phases. I think the most recent indication
is that they feel, you know, certainly they
can do another bank. But they cannot substitute
the quote-unquote reputation of the World
Bank.
But I would say just one thing I found always
kind of I will say frustrating -- and every
time they talk about China, they're always,
you know, we lecture them -- our safeguard.
My own view is working in the World Bank,
I think we -- in the World Bank, we can do
so much more for emerging market. If we just
relax in terms of how we solve problem rather
than insisting certain things, sometimes really
in my view is not practical.
That's why for the longest time I feel -- you
know, we talk about Ebola. I just with Dr.
Kim went to Ebola countries. I -- is a -- you
know, they're a lot of work to do. The truth
is the World Bank -- we have been operating
in many countries for so long; we need to
see faster buildup on infrastructure. We need
to do a lot of things.
I think I agree with the ambassador here.
If we find a way to work with the Chinese
and they have so much more capital to deploy,
they're looking for some kind of a partnership
because after all this trial -- if three years
ago, if you said let's be partners, I don't
think the Chinese -- hey, we can do it on
our own. But right now, they realize it's
not that fun; it's very difficult to do things
on their own.
So, I think there's opportunity here. I'm
not too sure -- call that mistake -- you know,
the partnership can be built, even starting
from now. So, I feel, you know, at least from
the World Bank perspective, we're have been
a lot of positive inclination trying to be
a partner with the new bank if that bank ever
going to be in operation.
ECONOMY: Thanks. OK, right here, yeah.
QUESTION: Thank you. Jack Goldstone, Woodrow
Wilson Center in George Mason University.
I have a question about the university sector.
They just announced a crackdown on deviant
thinking for universities. Now, my question
is does the Chinese leadership really understand
what's necessary for a knowledge economy and
innovation?
They have set targets for patents and generated
thousands of incremental, insignificant patents.
They've set targets for faculty to publish
in journals and unleashed a flood of plagiarism
and massive duplication of submissions to
journals. They've encouraged faculty to give
lectures; they've turned them into junkets.
So, they understand setting targets. They
don't seem to me to understand that a knowledge
economy really requires freedom of expression,
freedom of inquiry and open thought. Do you
think they get that and are just sitting on
it or do they really have to work to understand
this?
(LAUGHTER)
HUNTSMAN: Dr. Cai...
ECONOMY: Right.
COTE: If we eliminate deviant...
HUNTSMAN: That's tailor-made for you.
CAI: Here -- here -- here is the issue, right?
At the beginning, I mentioned it -- the government
for the last thirty years -- the government
believes it can do wonders. Anything government
want to do can be achieved. But this is one
area that's not going to be that easy.
I would say there's a -- more and more recognition.
Right now, you know, the university is almost
like a bureaucracy right now, as exactly what
you said.
So, while this can continue and there are
a lot of new interesting development, I don't
know if you -- I always follow this latest
development.
Jack Ma just set up a new university. Who
-- who is on his board? The (inaudible) -- Hank
would know -- Dr. Chen, my good friend; he's
the director -- I mean the dean of the school
of economic management in the Beijing University.
There's some U.S.-educated, I'll say leaders
-- real education leaders, and they are getting
on the board.
So, there -- I think -- look, it's -- it's
a massive system; 7 million graduates each
year. I mean, it's -- it's not going to be
easy. But you start to see some interesting
examples.
I think over time, I hope we will get to,
you know, what's the bureaucratization -- whatever
they call it -- that's the term they call
it right now, yeah.
ALBRIGHT: There's one other side to this that
I think is worth looking at. There are American
universities that do not wish to deal with
Chinese universities because of what you're
talking about.
And I think that what happens then when there
aren't exchange programs is we are basically
undercutting our own issues by not allowing
the people-to-people exchanges and having
the kind of issues that students can talk
about.
And so, that -- I definitely think there's
a problem in terms of what they're doing.
But I hope that it does mean that those that
I teach -- those of us that are involved in
education and people-to-people and student
exchanges -- don't decide we don't want anything
to do with them.
COTE: I'd say at the same time -- I have to
add this -- given I guess that I'm an honorary
professor at Beihang University...
(LAUGHTER)
And just outside of Beijing. And I -- what
I find absolutely fascinating about their
commitment to education -- so, not that the
deviant thinking is such a great thing to
I guess encourage or discourage; I wonder
how many kids we'd have left in school if
we took that out.
(LAUGHTER)
But at the end of the day, they still have
this commitment to math and science education
that is unbelievably impressive. And when
I go there to talk to them, which is about
once a year, everything's in English. So,
all the kids are taught in English, all the
math and science classes are in English; they're
learning everything in English from the first
day they get there and they have thousands
of kids enrolled in this aeronautical university.
How many kids do you think we'd get in the
U.S. if we said we're going to have an aeronautical
university and you're going to learn everything
in Mandarin? How many kids would go? Yet they
have thousands who want to do this.
And I wouldn't lose sight of what their university
system can produce.
HUNTSMAN: I would just say I think one of
their longer-term aspirations is to create
a research university. I think they envy our
research university model.
Now, why do I say that? For all kinds of reasons,
not least of all the -- the cyber intrusions
into certain research universities here that
are focused on translational research. They
don't do it; we do, better than anybody in
the world. And I think that's where they'd
like to be in the future.
They'd love to incubate, nurture, innovate
and translate it into the marketplace. I think
that's something they -- they really envy
about our system. And I do believe that on
the educational side, they will move more
and more in that direction along with other
educational innovations that I think are going
to be quite profound in the country.
COTE: I -- I agree with you.
CAI: And if I may add just one point here...
(LAUGHTER)
ECONOMY: OK...
CAI: Very interesting. I...
ECONOMY: We're going to lose...
CAI: In the past, I never -- you know, always
-- can China innovate. If you go to Shenzhen
nowadays, it's amazing. I mean, when I was
a banker, I always, oh, really good there
-- any -- you know, (inaudible). This guy
was educated in China, right? We called Beijing
a German institute -- 5,000 young scientists.
I think China is on its way to become a leader
in that -- bioengineering, bioscience. There
are massive amounts of innovation, I -- technology;
not necessarily in the other area, but at
least in technology, I am very hopeful. I
mean, I'm positively surprised.
HUNTSMAN: But it's certainly appropriate that
Jack Ma, a friend...
ALBRIGHT: Yeah.
HUNTSMAN: ...who failed the entry exam three
times to get into college is leading the efforts
toward reform. I think that's awesome.
(LAUGHTER)
ECONOMY: OK, this is unfortunately going to
have to be our last question. Go ahead, sir.
QUESTION: Would you say a few words about
the Russia-China entente and whether -- what
-- how China views that? Do they see it as
an opportunity to make Russia into a vassal
state? Do they see Russia as a...
(LAUGHTER)
...as a -- as a -- as a tributary? Do they
see it as an equal? I don't think so. But
I'd love to have some comments on that. Thank
you.
ALBRIGHT: Well, I think they are finding it
very useful and the Russians are certainly
going along with it. You have the expert sitting
next to you in terms of building pipelines
and trying to figure out how to deal with
China's energy issues.
I do think that there is a reconstitution
terms -- kind of a who's in power where, who
are the global powers. And we have seen periods
of history where the Chinese-Russian relationship
has been close and others where they have
gone opposite ways.
But I think it is a testing period and I imagine
that at the moment, frankly, China is in a
much stronger position in making deals than
the Russians are, and trying to figure out
what they can get out of it and how important
it is to them. I think it's fascinating to
watch and I bet you that they also talk about
how we play in that game.
ECONOMY: And how do you think they talk about
that -- about how...
(LAUGHTER)
ALBRIGHT: Well, I -- I think that they can
often find that they have more in common with
each other than with us, certainly in terms
of length of borders and various issues. But
I also think that the Chinese are smart enough
to know that their most important relationship
is with us, just as I believe that our most
important relationship in the 21st century
is with them.
ECONOMY: OK, I think that's an excellent note
on which to end our discussion this evening.
Let me please ask all of you to join me in
thanking our wonderful panelists.
(APPLAUSE)